a slum in west delhi for many residents
what is already a hard life has gotten
tougher since a major outbreak of dengue
and chikungunya in the city many have
fallen prey to the viral infections
transmitted by mosquitoes which breed
and thrive in unsanitary conditions and
pools of stagnant freshwater the slum is
home to tens of thousands of migrant
workers who earn a living in nearby
factories Gullu Kumar Paswan works as a
labourer in a manufacturing facility the
18 year old is suffering from severe
joint pain fever and fatigue telltale
symptoms of chikungunya patients are
usually prescribed painkillers and rest
I'm go I gotta save Oh Carla guy I've
had a high fever of one week and haven't
been able to go to work my company
doesn't pay me when I don't show up so
I'm losing out on my wages things are
really difficult up there with a nine
mil Gaya company i did here with
hundreds of workers like golu affected
over 1000 businesses located in my upper
e an industrial hub are grappling with
production losses this factory
manufactures fireproof dolls almost
fifteen percent of the workforce here is
down with some form of viral illness
specialized cutting machines a lying
idle and healthy employees are forced to
work overtime factory owner near it's a
girl who was sick himself with viral
fever says he's fallen behind with his
orders a war we're a small scale
industry we don't have backups there's a
shortage of workers everywhere it's a
huge problem for us for production and
for-profits the outbreak is hit Delhi's
economy hard with workers staying away
roadworks infrastructure projects to
have been delayed in several places
clinics and hospitals are full of people
lining up with complaints of the viral
illnesses this one in southwest delhi
sees about 40 such patients each day
this particular illness in this season
is virtually reach an epitome
proportion house2house people are
infected in a family people 425 they
already get infected because the
mosquito bites them in the early morning
hours each one of them and the mosquito
is try the transmitting the virus very
quickly the Delhi government however has
been slow off the mark it's under fire
for what critics say is a lacks and
inefficient response to the health
crisis a dwindling workforce and falling
productivity the government needs to get
a handle on the outbreak if Delhi's
economy is to recover